pj washington
for his names speaking of pjs
private jeff washington had a very
public uh
yeah so it was like pj washington was
dating this like famous thought named uh
brittany renner yeah
this is the girl that wrote the tell-all
book about everybody she slept with
she's super head for this generation
oh yes she's a new superhead yeah right
yeah also kind of a piece yeah kind of
kind of
um and uh so she was with this uh this
basketball player pj washington i
believe he plays for the washington
wizards
and um
she gets pregnant
baby comes out i think a month after
yeah divorces him
and now
allegedly is gonna get 200 000 a month
in child support and then videos popped
up of her back in the day saying if you
really want to come up off a check just
get pregnant by an nba player or by an
athlete because they never want to wear
condoms yeah they're stupid and they're
stupid they're the easiest ones to trick
and yada yada yada so people are putting
these things together and they're saying
oh my gosh she totally tricked him she
was never into him yeah first place she
just got up a check in the second the
baby came out she was like you want to
pay me for the rest of this baby's life
yeah now there is some discrepancy in
terms of how much she's going to be
making a month on this but uh 200 000 a
month sounds absolutely ridiculous how
much is that for 18 years
i mean 43 million i think wow that was a
great match no i think i saw it
somewhere oh i saw it somewhere and i
think it was 40. take credit for that
[ __ ] bro come on i don't know because
then you asked me if you asked me to
calculate it
but uh but it is it is kind of [ __ ]
crazy man i have a feeling that that's
not how much it is and i also have a
feeling like
you know if you're gonna be like an open
thought yeah like you've got some
emotional issues
oh yeah i do and who knows maybe pj
washington's got some emotional issues
like people getting divorced especially
people in public relationships is not
rare this happens all the goddamn time
so i don't like to go at this that she
has some like diabolical plans to get
nutted in by some basketball player and
then just collect checks for the rest of
her life that is maybe what happened how
old is he though 22 22 she's 27. she got
some and how long they've been together
maybe you could say she groomed him i
think some people were trying to
i mean come on grow up bro can you groom
an adult yeah
[ __ ] for women you say when this girl
got groomed but you get groomed when
you're underage like he's 22 years old
like you got to take some accountability
like i ain't doing that [ __ ] with dudes
bro you got grooms
you got groomed you were literally a
groom
she grooms your ass yeah okay and that's
why you're paying two hundred thousand
dollars a month because you let this
[ __ ] go yeah i got groomed this past
july i got groomed yeah yeah yeah yeah i
bought a fake tv you know i got groomed
i got it i wasn't gypped you know i was
i was an idiot i wasn't a mark i got
groomed you got groomed you know so
that's why it is it's like come on dudes
you should be you should know better
than this and if she if she convinced i
don't know my assumption i actually
think that they like got along it worked
out all of a sudden she gets pregnant
she's different who knows what he was
doing maybe he was doing some wild [ __ ]
nobody's talking about that yeah cause
her history is she sucks
yeah this is the girl that wrote the
[ __ ] colin kaepernick had sex with me
but he wouldn't pay for my flights over
and like who gives a [ __ ] oh that's
right king yo real king yeah it's kind
of a hero yo that is a real [ __ ] king
yeah yeah absolutely that's an
interesting conversation that nobody's
talking about right now is uh
is is kaepernick gonna get vaxxed
oh no dog he took a knee on that vaccine
i bet because that's a tricky one yeah
yeah right cause now
he gotta agree with all the people who
hated him
right
oh if he doesn't get the facts if he
doesn't get facts if he's anti-vex now
he's got some common ground with all the
people that hated him for taking a knee
i don't think he has a problem having
common ground with them though i think
they might have a problem having common
ground with him you don't think that he
has a problem having common ground with
the if it's just if it's like uh we
share medical views i don't think he
cares right right political views maybe
it would be funny though if he came out
super anti-vaxx and now all the people
that hate him have a real [ __ ]
quandary on their hands like yeah can we
support this guy burn my jersey
what do i do he's about to be their hero
yeah and nike gonna collect oh dog 100
he got to come out his anti-vac strong
like you're gonna make that [ __ ]
jersey just don't do it yeah yeah
yeah we gotta do it we gotta see man
that'd be an interesting thing but yeah
the britney reddit thing i don't know
man did we stop nothing in these girls
bro 43 million over 18 years that's what
it is i don't think it's that i don't
think she's gonna get that but still
like what the [ __ ]
i mean what the [ __ ] yeah i mean i guess
your 21 year old basketball player these
guys are like [ __ ] a bad [ __ ]
i think they were together for a while
also like these guys are idiots mostly
she's right like he just you're a
professional basketball player he's been
coddled your entire [ __ ] life you
know ever since you're in high school
you're the superstar well i think
there's a shift you go from not being
coddled having the shittiest life ever
correct it sucks super hard and then all
of a sudden incredibly cold everyone
loves you you're like the hero of your
town yeah and then you have to do that
transition in like eight months yeah but
i think that starts earlier now that i
think there was a time when that was
what it was like like when people were
undiscovered even until college yeah but
i think now because there's so much
money in basketball make college money
and [ __ ] even college money before that
like i think there are people that are
out there scouting you in middle school
yeah like you are hooping in middle
school they know that you're nice you're
going to all the basketball camps and
they're all the same camps everybody you
know having a social media presence is
popping there's high schoolers with
millions of followers exactly that
doesn't change the fact that like you
got abused by your mom or like your dad
wasn't there when you were eight or
whatever i don't know if that's the case
is that the case with him i don't know i
mean he could be some rich kid for all
we [ __ ] yeah right so it's like
but you're in that situation where most
of these guys they don't develop any
real social skills and that's gonna [ __ ]
a relationship up too like if you just
had your ass kissed your whole life and
all of a sudden you got a girl and then
she's telling you what to do you're like
why are you telling me things yeah
people just kiss my ass i haven't booked
a single flight i don't book where i eat
dinner i just got tons of money i can
spend it where the [ __ ] i want i am the
man and you're treating me like i'm not
that's going to create a riff in a
relationship don't you think like that's
gonna be hard to be with now i'm not
saying this is his fault but we're
automatically looking at this girl who
is dotting it around for a while and
sleeping with a lot of celebs and
writing [ __ ] books about it we're
automatically looking about like she's
the one who planned this whole [ __ ]
thing we don't know no he could be a
social ninja poop he could have no clue
how to maintain a relationship true and
why would these guys why would they even
have a relationship it's not shocking
the first relationship that an nba
player gets into and has a kid gets
[ __ ] up that's not shocking to me yeah
you out there on the road you could be
getting [ __ ] as [ __ ] this is the tricky
thing about putting your whole life on
she's like i put my [ __ ] on ice for you
and you just started cheating on me with
other groupie i'm a groupie you have
both yeah you have groupie [ __ ] and
wife [ __ ] this is the best of both
worlds
you [ __ ] it up the dangerous thing
about putting your whole life online and
though it's now you've given everybody
context for who you are yeah her context
is she sucks yeah he didn't do that i
mean he probably does but he's not big
on social media so we don't know any of
his context he's just a guy so it's very
easy when heart context sucks depending
here's a piece of [ __ ] and him as a
sweet kid more evidence against her
there's way more evidence against her
and it's also the internet wants to hate
her more why would you hate him you know
he's the guy that you would love to be
he'd love to be in the nba and have an
85 million contractor 43 million
whatever the [ __ ] he got right
and the girl that you hate the most is
this gold digging [ __ ] yeah because you
hate women like that because they're the
ones that rejected you because you ain't
got no gold to dig so of course the
internet is going to go crazy over there
if you're a woman you're like man this
girl got paid for doing nothing like i'm
over here i got to work double [ __ ] the
wendy's and this girl's getting paid 200
000 a month to just sit in her [ __ ]
ass yeah work out whatever it is so we
don't know what it is we don't know the
whole situation but i don't know man
like i i think a lot of people don't
realize a lot of these athletes are just
like
they do not have the social skills
they're not good with girls they're like
uncomfortable and awkward around girls
they got no free time like they're
literally spending all day working out
[ __ ] doing their [ __ ] that's it and
when they're not they're just hanging
with their buddies playing video games
they're nerds yeah it's not like it was
back in the day back in the day you
still had to be kind of cool kid in the
neighborhood you might have come from
like a rough situation you might even
been if you like really from the hood
you might even been banging right up
until you went to college yeah yeah you
know so it's like you were still trying
to get [ __ ] on the side and these girls
didn't give a [ __ ] that you were in high
school playing bad they didn't know you
were going to go to the nba yeah now
they know yeah and every girl in high
school goes he's going to the nba yeah
if you think the ball brothers didn't
have groupies in high school yachts
goddammit oh yeah you know what i mean
like if you think lebron didn't have
groupies in high school you actually got
damn minds yeah you're a superstar since
you're 16 years old probably right so
yeah should every nba team just have
like a team therapist they do yeah are
they required to go to see them they do
they're not required but the smart ones
actually go and they get something from
i'm like if you're required to go to the
gym you got to be required to get your
mental and your emotional figured out
right and that's to be honest that's on
the gms yeah
every
he's the thing is he's not
i don't want to say not good enough but
he's not uh successful enough of a
player to have like a handler right he's
not making a huge game impact yeah yeah
but every player on the team that's like
big time has a handler right they have a
personal guy who's there yeah to make
sure they have everything they need
right plus a personal agent plus a
personal age on that side
you'll like take care of [ __ ] if you
need it yes this girl giving me this
problem this girl won't leave my hotel
room got it don't worry about it we'll
work on it yeah and they're there as a
liaison for the team right now
sometimes it's an assistant coach
sometimes somebody outside the
organization but the worse you are the
less people care about you yep simple as
that so he probably didn't have somebody
on the team going yo i just want to let
you know
that
this chick has been around a little bit
so you should be careful like dirk you
know remember when dirk got caught up in
that [ __ ] yeah dude so they were telling
that they had a they got a team yeah the
mavs had a guy on the team that told
dirk
the deal with the girl right be careful
yeah but he was caught up in that black
[ __ ] for the first time it's a german
kid
you know what i mean he never had that
southern black [ __ ] it's a different
game yeah
okay
so
it didn't work but afterwards there was
a lot of trust that was built because
the guy basically warned him right so do
not get got
you